bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur deluna
télé pour suivre la suite de ce
championnat du monde 2015 féminin avec
marie ses bagues en huitièmes de finale
donc match retour mari qui donc remporté
la première manche qui mène donc 1-0
donc la russe maintenant pour go nina
doit absolument l'emporter pour tenter
de jouer maintenant les tie breaks sont
quoi évidemment elle sera directement
éliminé donc il faut pour marie
simplement une partie nulle voire
pourquoi pas un gamin sur et elle est
qualifiée directement donc c'est parti
pour ce huitième de finale retour de
championnat du monde 2015 entre pogo
nina et marie c bat donc il ya les noirs
cette fois c'est parti
des quatre des cinq c4 et c6 donc là on
est habitué depuis ce championnat du
monde c'est ce que vous marie cette
fameuse défense slave qu'elle a joué
qu'elle joue indifféremment d'ailleurs
on l'a vu mais monsieur que sur ce cas
des quatre c4 ou alors on l'a vu sur la
catalane avec g3 c'est la même structure
donc elle est habituée apparemment joué
cette ouverture donc cavalier 3 et 6 se
regarder comment on attend avant de
sortir ce fou éventuellement on laisse
la possibilité de de sortir pourquoi pas
avant de jouer aussi ce même si c'est
pas forcément ce qu'il va se passer
qu'avait laissé 3,6 quand même voilà
maintenant on peut plus sortir le fou
donc c'est le problème on est très fort
sur case blanche mais on a un fou qui
pour l'instant est enfermé le 3
qu'à valider cette dame c'est 2 tout est
harmonieux du côté blanc à noter que les
blancs aussi on vous enfermez phocéen
est dans la même position que le fou
noir
ici il est bloqué et mais parfois les
blancs jouent donc b3 pour le mettre en
b2 en visant le centre quand même par
transparence on contrôle la case de 5-fu
des six normales food et 3
hélas petit rock petit rock c'est pas la
même que celle qu'on avait vu
précédemment avec marie qui avait des
blancs puisque là les blancs en rock et
si vous vous rappelez à la fois les
blancs avaient par ok quand elle a joué
le coup qui va suivre c'est à dire e5
voilà alors libération pour les noirs
rapide on joue une scène rapidement sans
doute avant qu'on ne puisse pas le jouer
donc là l'idée c'est maintenant qu'on a
rockets et que tout est sorti comme il
faut on a sorti nos pièces on peut jouer
5 avec pas trop de danger puisque donc
l'on est à l'abri mais on l'a vu aussi
sa sacrée comme un problème en dessin
puisque potentiellement après échange
échange les noirs auront un pion isolé
il faut sans doute échangé aux cinq
d'abord mais voilà on voit que
structurellement c'est un peu un peu
tendu mais bon c'est une libération
rapide aussi voilà donc avantages et
inconvénients
donc les blancs prénoms des 5 une
première fois prises prise très bien et
la e 4 alors là c'est une contre attaque
un blanches c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu de
prendre un e 5 qui sera nous soit un peu
passif les blancs choisissent de contre
attaquer au centre et la position on le
voit elle est ma merveilleuse avec deux
pions blancs 4 des 4 2 pions noirs e5
des cinq grosses pressions des prises
partout possible alors que faire c'est
pas évident c'est pas évident parce que
regarder si les noirs prennent en quatre
par exemple on voit que après cavalli
prend 1,4 s'attaque le fou
si on prend et bien le four prend et en
menace fou prend h7 avec échec
donc on n'a pas le temps de finir les
échanges au centre donc on peut pas
vraiment liquider tous les pions au
centre il ya toujours la menace à la fin
fou prend h7 qui pose un problème si si
le cavalier noir a mis à contribution
donc bon alors on voit ce que j'adore
c'est quand même en noir de jouer donc
prise cette fois donc en d4 se trompent
pas pourquoi pas et là bon s'il est
blanc reprennent les noirs sont contents
je pense parce qu'ils prennent à eux
quatre ils liquident et je pense que les
blancs rien donc il faut pas reprendre
en d4 mais jouer ce que je voulais blanc
sans doute très bons cavaliers prendre
cavaliers prend il va rester des pions
au centre avec une position il faudra
voir après à la fin parce que c'est
compliqué encore donc là les noirs ont
encore plein coup possible ici on peut
jouer sans doute tour 8 mais le mieux
c'est sans doute de prendre ce cavalier
qui quand même au centre cavaliers prend
puis on prend très bien le pion des
quatre étangs de prix du café f3 et le
pion des 5 semble pas pouvoir tenir
longtemps parce que on peut jouer
cavalier bicis pas qu'à lille 6 parce
qu'on aurait pu se faire clouer à noter
aussi là qu'il ya quand même
fou prend 7 qui menace un silo blanc de
jouer faut prendre cette menace doit
donc là les blancs les noirs pardon
doivent d'abord défendre epci six
cavaliers m6 peut montrer c'est pas un
très très bon coup sans doute puisque de
l'iaaf ou du projet seine qui peut
menacer
même si bon c'est pas très grave en fait
non plus jouer 6 quand même c'est
jouable mais ça va être dur de prendre
le pion des 500 jouets geisen qui
affaiblit quand même le roc bon alors
c'est possible de jouer ou g5 sans doute
bon c'est une position encore théorique
un très certainement on va pas analyser
ça trop longtemps donc h6 alors mieux
12e coup et après tour d un mari
réfléchi très longtemps cavaliers et f6
alors déjà alors aux environs de ce coup
là je crois que c'est avant tout sur ce
coup-là savoir que la mariée a joué à
dépenser quasiment la totalité de son
temps ça c'est incroyable ce qu'on est
qu'au 13e coup quand même ça c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle un championnat du
monde de perdre autant de temps donc il
doit lui rester bon gré du temps encore
20 minutes mais il nous reste encore
trente sept coups à jouer avant le 40e
coup et voilà donc s'il reste 20 minutes
alors il reste 20 minutes + 30 secondes
parcours est bien sûr mais bon voilà une
heure trente de capital au départ tout
gaspillé comme ça dans les premiers
coups bon h3 donc en tout si on suit le
match comme ça forcément ça donne des
sueurs froides quand on voit le temps
comme ça alors h3 très bien les blancs
empêche aussi fauché quatre voiliers on
se presse pas de prendre les pions
centre à noter que la tour d un des
blancs c'est comme très désagréable du
côté noir parce qu'on section fait des
échanges au centre on a un vis-à-vis
tour dames donc les blancs semblent
quand même mieux placé que les noires la
cause à la fin c'est toujours un petit
avantage de début c'est normal c'est lui
l'homme qui débute faut pas oublier donc
aller prendre des scènes bon très bien
pourquoi pas hélas les blancs auraient
pu faire cavalier prendre des cartes
bien entendu pour reprendre
on peut aussi jouer pourquoi pas fous
ces quatre attaques lecavalier
dessalement sans doute fou le 6 mai sur
fou au cices le cavalier pratiquer le
foot bon voilà tout ça est compliqué et
là les blancs jouent une variante plus
tendu et très intéressante fou échec
droit je suis efforcé alors génère on ne
fait pas ce genre de court parce que le
fou et soule à l'emprise du roi donc la
dame est obligé de rester sur la
diagonale et on peut jouer parfois g6 et
le foot enfermé bon souvent j'ai s'ils
sont simplement le fou se sacrifie on a
deux pions du rock avec un roi faible il
faut y réfléchir à deux fois ici avant
de jouer j'ai 6 ans ne s'est pas défendu
mais mais ça peut tout à fait jouer ses
deux pions pour la pièce c'est tout à
fait intéressant mais les blancs
maintenant quand même une menace ils
vont jouer tout simplement le coup très
fort tout reprend alors là c'est pénible
parce qu'on voit bien que le car il est
attaqué le fou aussi on la dame derrière
mais le x 7 étant fermée aussi donc
c'est quand même bon et on voit bien que
l'initiative est quand même du côté
blanc avec un joue quand même fluide on
voit que le fou là
pas tarder à sortir non plus il est déjà
libéré bon le fou ces huit devrez non
plus ne devrait pas non plus trop tarder
à sortir mais il a moins de gaz que ce
fou parce que ce choix de belles cases
une fois que le carrière a été obligé de
jouer
bon
à noter quand même que sur fou au 6 de
la part des noirs mais le fou revient à
1,4 et la pression continue et si
j'enlève le cavalier mon fils cloud et
l'a donc faut être quatre et on risque
de perdre une pièce parce que pour
l'instant il y en a quand même égalité
de pièces alors mari joue quelque chose
de sans doute qui est sans doute le
meilleur mais elle réfléchit beaucoup et
il va nous rester genre quelque chose
comme 6 minutes à la pendule
alors qu'on est au 16e coup voilà elle a
mis encore plus de temps pour jouer ça
donc là il faut savoir que maintenant le
mari étant quasi et notes jusqu'au 40e
coup elle va devoir jouer 24 coup
maintenant 11 et notes c'est pas très
sérieux ça fait peur
alors les blancs se trompent pas
tranquillement attention parce que si
les blancs enlève le fou on peut mais
dans ce cas la dame sort sans doute en
faisait en vis-à-vis d'am-dam proposant
un échange une simplification si les
dames sont plus dans le jeu peut penser
que les initiatives l'enjeu va
disparaître parce qu'il donne une
initiative au blanc c'est bien sûr le
fait que leur tour est sorti voyez quand
alors que les noirs leur tour est encore
à la maison le fou s'éviter pas sorti le
fou c est non plus qui fait davantage
ses sept tours qui en plus est en
clouage par rapport à la dame noire dont
kyle si c'est bien ça enlève une des
pièces cloué et en mettant ces attaques
le fou donc faut pas perdre de temps
avec les blancs sinon cet avantage va
fondre fouet ce qu'a très bien continuer
le développement
le fou est perdu mais bien sûr je me
venge sur h7
je voulais prendre du cavalier puisque
la dame contrôle qu'avaient les prendre
et là sans doute le meilleur c'est tout
reprendre et non pas fou prend et les
blancs font fou prend bon tour prend
c'est mieux pourquoi parce qu'on veut la
ta dam est attaquée est obligé de on est
obligé de jouer la dame on n'a pas de
bonnes cases facile pour la dame où il
va pas facile faut sans doute aller en a
5 mai à 5 jeux menace rien non plus ça
permet aux blancs de doubler les tours
rapidement bon vous prend et pas mauvais
bien sûr je gagne aussi en tant sur la
tour mais cette tourelle rêvent que de
ça de devenir sur huit
voilà elle vient à 8 donc elle se
développe donc j'ai pas vraiment gagner
de temps avec les blancs en venant des
six et si je rejoue le fou pour gagner
en temps sur la dame belge aurait joué
le fou deux fois donc j'ai pas vraiment
gagner de temps jeu
que tout reprend et plus plus fort en
terme de temps bon peu importe tant
mieux pour marie dame b 3 bon c'est pas
mal c'est une autre idée j'ai sorcier
lettre j'ai fait sortir la tour mais
dans la dame qui a enlevé trois c'est
très fort parce que j'attaque et vii
bon je dis c'est pas très très grave un
peu défendre yves set mais j'ai un oeil
aussi sur bessette donc comment je vais
sortir mon fou voyez c'est le problème
des petits coups comme ça qui m qui
augmente la pression la dame a fini son
travail sur ces deux bons l'histoire sur
h7 c'est fini je viens en b3 et j'ai un
oeil sur f7 il faut que les noirs
répondent et en plus j'ai mis la dame en
position d'attaqué bessette donc le fou
c'est 8 a du mal à sortir à moins de
simplifier le pion donc le roi revient
au g8
c'est bien parce qu'évidemment le roi
c'est s'il peut pas trop loin du centre
en prévision d'une fine à lutter
ultérieure c'est pas plus mal mais je
perds un temps bon sur le temps que les
blancs perdu âge me x 7
ils l'ont récupéré du fait que les noirs
sont obligés de rejouer roi g8
voilà c'est aux blancs de jouer est très
bien très jolie clavier ou cinq au bon
moment là le cavalier vient au sein une
menace mais évidemment en offset soit
cavaliers prend soin d'en prend avec
d'emprunt roi je suis obligé si ce matin
attention menace de maths ça peut aller
vite donc il faut jouer le coup suivant
mémoire pas de problème votre précis
mais il n'y a pas de souci d'un même si
très bien la multi ce solide
je tiens f7 bon
les noirs pourraient tenter des coups
quand même ici par exemple j'ai 3 semble
intéressant sans craindre fou prend h3
parce que la menace pourrait être de
jouer tour f4 attaque et 7,3 fois voilà
mais bon on s'en doute les noirs ici
peuvent jouer cavalier g5 attaque
h3 faisant échec et en cas de tours f4
lecavalier protéger cet après on pourra
jouer peut-être faut aussi sans
sacrifier le pion là mais on pourrait
puis on a dû contre eux sur le fou des
six aussi donc c'est pas très grave
voilà donc tour à d voilà c'est quand
même mieux double les tours comme ça et
pas de pièce en l'air parce que la tour
des quatre étais pas protéger ses biens
est la dernière pièce est en jeu donc
toutes les pièces blanches sont
développées et les noirs ont des
problèmes le fossé 8 est pas sorti et
donc la torah 8 non plus mais leur
position est solide on voit que
structurellement en termes de pioncer
solide n'y a pas de souci et puis alors
les noirs bon vu qu'ils peuvent pas
sortir leurs poubelles et active au
moins leurs cavaliers c'est vrai que ce
cavalier de perrache 7 est mal placé un
cavalier comme ça qui est loin du centre
loin du jeu sur une bande comme ça c'est
pas bon il faut le ramener vers le
centre donc avalé gsm très bien
accueilli g5
c'est bien pourquoi pas les sacrifices
hurajt juan certaines positions morales
à damas attention la dame protège daniel
pion et la dame donc il n'y a pas de pas
d'idées on sait jamais ça peut arriver
et en venant ici je peux aussi me
recycler en russie ce le problème si je
viens aussi ce avec lecavalier le fou
c'est 8 a toujours pas de cadre sama
relève en plus une canne donc on a des
problèmes de développement
mais bon il faut que les blancs
démontrent que leur avance de
développement leur permet de créer des
menaces sinon ça sert à rien hélas les
blancs jouent h4 bon h4
c'est pas c'est pas forcément le mieux
ça affaiblit un peu ce pion mais bon
c'est vrai que les blancs essaye de
mettre en mouvement leur leur petit
avantage qui est quand même davantage de
dynamique qu'ils ont développé leur
pièce qui tiennent le centre ça peut
être une idée de 2 d'avancé les pions de
les droits pour aussi de créer des
menaces mais la position nord est solide
il ya quand même une dame en défend son
cavalier bon alors ceci dit qu avait lui
aussi s'est quasiment forcé voilà là
comment je vais sentir m'en fous je suis
pas prêt 17 ses prix par le cavalier est
aussi c'est bouché je suis pas prêt de
sortir mes pièces tour 4 bien pourquoi
pas eh bien on change de colonne en
quatre il ya un vis-à-vis quand même
tour tourte la torre 8 est quand même en
l'air bon donc si lecavalier bouge il
peut se passer des trucs pareils cas
mais j'ai quatre attaques la dame et
menacent tout reprend 1,8
bon pourquoi pas ceci dit ce coup semble
pas extrêmement pêchue il ici pouvait y
avoir peut-être des coûts plus plus
tendu par exemple la base de dame b 5
contre attaque la tour ici où va la tour
pas évident bon ou la garde et la
colonne départs tour des 3 ce genre de
choses mais bien sûr les blancs ont un
problème parce qu'ils veulent
il ya est le pion h4 qui emprise ils
n'ont pas envie de sacrifier un pion
il aurait pu bon pourquoi pas bon
peut-être que il n'y a pas d'eau trop de
choix tour canon c'est pas mauvais coups
de toute façon ça garde aussi le contact
c'est une autre raison il ya un
vis-à-vis du retour ça va être
intéressant
et puis on garde le contrôle du pion h4
alors on l'a encore marie réfléchit
beaucoup donc c'est stressant si on suit
le match donc je suivais un peu le match
en direct ses fruits quand on voit le
temps
qu'on les noirs on se dit bon reste plus
que genre deux minutes ou 3 à marie plus
30 secondes parcours donc ça laisse du
temps mais pour trouver des coûts dans
ce type d'opposition ça demanderait un
tout petit peu plus de temps
bon alors une idée ça aurait pu être de
jouer par exemple cavaliers en fuite
pourquoi mais en général on aime bien
rocardien fuite ça défend très bien
droit on va pas donner le fou contre un
cavalier on sait que en finale c'est pas
forcément bien et puis le fou maintenant
on va pouvoir ressortir à 1,6 par
exemple et sur d'emprunt c'est pas grave
puisque on prendrait à 2 voilà avec une
peau en aurait fini de le développement
des pièces avec une position
intéressante c'était possible bon alors
la marijuana ou tendu kalyev 4 bon c'est
un peu la même idée je peux
éventuellement venir à 1 600 craindre
d'en prendre 17 puisque je peux prendre
à deux peut-être tout simplement at il
une pièce contre un pion et puis j'ai
aussi en jouant cavalier en f4 j'ai
aussi la possibilité de faire d'un
proche 4 d'un proche 4g trois attaques
dames et cavaliers se heurte à cavalier
échec aura bouge et la tour est perdu
voyez comme c'est le problème de palier
les tours 1 si on ajoute les taux en cas
de la tour 4 et pas défendu donc il ya
une menace en hqe a donc là le cavalier
f4 en quelque sorte coupe la tour alors
le problème c'est le coup suivant des
blancs très jolie dame à 4 c'est quoi le
problème mais c'est très net attaque la
tour e 8 et le cavalier f4 alors c'est
chaud parce que là on voit bien qu'il ya
un souci
heureusement il ya un coût qui sauve les
blancs au prix d'un pion b5
c'est le seul coup bon l'avantagent
contourne temps n'a pas beaucoup de
temps c'est que
quand ya pas beaucoup de cours les
trouve et ça nous évite de réfléchir on
peut être content mais on donne un pion
déjà les blancs prennent un pion mais 5
alors là l'idée c'est que on enlève la
dame de la quatrième donc et en plus on
empêche la dame ici d'attaquer la tour
donc si la dame reste sur as
par exemple si la dame 10 rb 4 on joue à
5 toujours en islande déstabiliser cette
dame
et si la dame viande et katia plus que
lecavalier d'attaqué et plus la tour
si on prend ici la togruta taquet mais
pas le cavalier voyez donc en fait on
perturbe en jambes et celles qui ont
perturbé la coordination de la dame ici
qui attaqué à la fois la tour et le
cavalier f4 faut connaître ce genre de
coups désorganise la puissance des
pièces blanches d'un premier simple
vient c'est pas très très graves pour
les noirs bon c'est pas c'était
peut-être mieux d'avoir joué peu de lait
noir avait joué kabylie est celui qui
aurait pas eu cette manoeuvre envoyé en
fuite ya pas double attaque
mais bon faut aussi ce bon certes gmt au
moins mais bon c'est pas la fin du monde
hk très faible si on joue g3 en
affaiblit son roi sur case blanche et
l'on n'entre fouilles sur casse blanche
donc ça peut c'est sûr même ça va donner
idées d'attac au noir et puis quand même
le pion à doc attaqué aussi donc si on
perd du temps pour le défendre
bon ben les noirs vont pouvoir se
réorganiser donc en échange d'un pion
quand même je reviens dans la partie bon
c'est pas très grave
les langues ou d'un à quatre n'est pas
le coup le plus tendu mais ça repose la
question cavaliers léger 6 très bien
c'est tout si l'idée de câbles f4 elle
voulait sans doute venir en g6 mais
ensuite le rafiot 6 1
je répète un nom quand éclate c'est s
était pas forcément leur case cavaliers
prendre quasiment forcé qui commençait à
avoir des menaces dans prend voilà très
bien
bon alors là à la tourette attaquer mais
la dame 1,4 protège le fou attention
parce que la dame vise g2 6e faut
arriver à aller sur la grande diagonale
ici pour y avoir des menaces de matos il
bon ça reste que rien pour l'instant et
voilà pour faire attention quand même le
la position est toujours la montage des
blancs il ya clairement un plongeon de
plus mais il le fait qu'on ait joué à
quatre a fait bien tout petit peu le
rock
si on arrivait à faire pour forcer les
blancs a joué 3 se fout ils crieraient
victoire il ya prix serait un il serait
un danger permanent alors très bien on
double pression
donc on peut pas bouger le fou sinon il
ya tout qui saute donc mari enlève la
tour de la colonne e et attaque
simplement le pouls des 6.5 très bien
alors là il y avait un très bon coup
pour marie qu'elle n'a pas vu mais elle
a pas beaucoup de temps c'est fou 17
pourquoi ben c'est un peu la même idée
c'est à dire que j'attaque la dame l'a
déstabilisé un tout petit peu et je vais
essayer de faire en sorte qu'elle quitte
la quatrième pourquoi parce que ici je
voudrais jouer fou des cinq attaques la
tour et menaces maths mais fou des cinq
si je le joue tout de suite ça se heurte
à tour chez quatre attaques la dame
protéger de la dame protège donc je joue
d'abord fou 17
j'attaque la dame où il va pas beaucoup
de bonnes cases si je vais en b 4 à 5
si je vais en c4 par exemple ici voilà
j'attaque avec l'autre tour il reste la
case des quatre mais cette décade c'est
pire puisque si je viens en d4
simplement je peut menacer matt
directement et la dermite attaqué et je
menace
nate et le fou en devenant h3 le fou
empêche tout rejet 4 voilà c'est encore
c'est pire donc surtout 17 et où va le
nouvel adam donc imaginons que la dame
ayant par exemple les baies 3 c'est un
des rares coups possibles je pense eh
bien les fous tu me fous maintenant
viendrai en c6 et c'est fini pouf g2 va
tomber si la tour bouge donc enfin
william a de quoi tout simplement et les
blancs seraient obligés à leurs pareils
la même idée tout à l'heure on avait
joué des scènes voyez-vous c'était pour
désorganiser c'est pareil on joue h5 on
donne le pion en espérant que sur
d'emprunt ya plus il ya plus de menaces
de mater dans ce clash préambule à tours
mais j'ai récupéré un pion pour les
noirs un pion gratuit alors on peut
jouer aussi
dames
g saint qui garde la menace mais on
continue f4 rappelez vous tout à l'heure
c'était pareil on avait joué bcm on
avait dit sur dame b 4 je jouais à 5
on met lass est un ami des joues harcèle
la dame pour la faire quitter cette
colonne qui est plus de maths
tu peux pas venir en g3 madame attention
elles et les attaques de travers on les
voit pas donc je suis par exemple si je
vais donc un g4 ce qui allait encore
possible maintenant je peux venir tours
2 voilà la dame latour protège de linge
et 2 et quand il prend nash c'est très
certainement le roi est affaibli comme
un nain voilà le roi blanc est très
faible ici donc là cette position est
quand même préférable pour les noirs
parce que ce que l'on récupère le pion
mais on a en plus aura blanc faible
voilà donc la marie rate ça
malheureusement
mais problème de temps donc faux c'est
fou dès cet été un très bon coup voilà
faut 17 sachant qu'en plus comme la dame
protège ses 6 alors à foug 17 je peux
jouer 6 pouces et six ans sans crainte
ou 17 pouces et 6 et ses shows l'a pas
vu je pense qu'elle leur a joué s'il
avait vu donc la torah si vite
bon ça alès le pion à 7 mais sans tout
alla pas peur d'eux dans prend 1,7 à
cause de fougue iv et vi voilà
alors les blancs jouent à 3 bidart alors
peut-être que les blancs se sont dit si
je prends à sept tours à huit et après
je prends à deux mois je pense que
l'idée était plutôt de jouer fou fou des
cinq bons à 3 bat là il ya toujours sous
17 encore food et cette même idée sur
dame b 4 el hacen quand même je donne le
pion et après je vais jouer vous et si
je gagne la qualité c'est pas facile
après pour les blancs parce que bon ils
ont deux pions certes pour la qualité
mais c'est quand même c'est ça va quand
même être difficile sur le roi c'est
déjà un peu affaibli donc bon alors au
lieu de quoi marie joue un coup faiblard
ici un rouage cette oreille c'est le
problème d'avoir réfléchi dit beaucoup
trop au début elle avait pas trouvé les
coups les plus précis ça c'est un coup
on faible c'est pas il n'y a pas urgence
à jouer et on achète quoi c'est ça c'est
vraiment un coût qui n'est pas bon fous
ces trois les blancs et c2 alors les
blancs aussi en jouant fous ces trois
voies la libère on peut l'action de leur
tour ici et puis ça empêche aussi que la
tour noire plus tard viennent en c2 par
une sorte d'empreinte n'aurait pas aimé
tour ces deux on peut pas le faire bon
alors maintenant mari le fait mais c'est
un peu trop tard lors pu le faire donc
il ya de couvoirs le coup précédent
c'est moins bien après dun prend à 7
pouces et 6 et blanc jouent h5
dames gsm quand même qu'on a vu d'accord
mais bon les blancs maintenant ils ont
eu le temps de jouer à trois donc ils
ont une ouïe a pas de tours à huit ya
rien du tout et puis après dame g5 c'est
pas tout à fait la même non plus puisque
on adam prend cette voie là on a joué
tour à ses 8 points avec les noirs donc
on a laissé son pion voilà donc là les
blancs ont trois pions contre la qualité
fou prend pour prendre donc malgré la
qualité de moins
les blancs on net avantage à noter aussi
qu'il ya quand même ici que on a deux
pions passé lié pour la qualité ce
terrain pour le foot ça suffit pour
gagner souvent voilà c'est une pièce
mineur et deux pions passé lié contre
une seul tour c'est souvent surtout un
fou c'est souvent gagnant pas toujours
un mais il m'est souvent donc bon tour
et cheikh rage deux tours ces scènes
très bien pour ses selles bah je vais
récupérer au moins un pion c'est vrai
que c'est difficile pour les blancs de
sauvegarder le troisième pion ici
puisque si on vous g4 ça va se faire
mater on va faire d'un match 4 échecs
subis de damas chain on perd la tour
enfin bon on perd tout c'est pas bon
donc les blancs ici comprenne qui peut y
avoir des attaques aussi donc simplement
échanger dame t'en prends h prend pour
apprend et deux pions passé lié pour la
qualité
l'avantagé toujours blanc bon c'est pas
forcément décisif décisif
ça joue bien sûr mais les blancs ont
l'avantagé est nettement
il suffit je rappelle quand même du nul
pour marie pour gagner le match
alors pour cette 39e coup il reste quoi
une minute deux minutes à la pendule de
mariée bon et bien aussi réfléchissent
donc il en reste un peu moins de temps
aussi hélas bon leur tentative
d'extorsion de fonds
tourache cinq échecs rouages les trois
tours j'ai cinq échecs à f3 bon on
active le roi blanc aussi l'ain monts
est ce qu'on a le choix parce que
attention
des blancs là vont récupérer g7 tour des
trois échecs à eux deux et c'est pas mal
marie transpose dans une finale
inférieur métaux nabeul sinon on perd le
troisième pion est vraiment ça va être
vraiment dur ce qu'on peut rien faire en
plus le fou très bien défendu il reste
un ses trois protégés par b2 va pousser
ses pions à 5 il est protégé et si on a
en plus un pion sur les droits de plus
on va pouvoir avancer des deux côtés les
tours vont souffrir
donc la regarder simplification tout
reprend puis on prend ça élimine la
menace sur g7 et simplement pranger 2
voilà alors c'est marrant fait c'est
marrant on note qu on a une finale qui
semble enfin qui est un peu cuisine
cette finale de celle que marie a gagné
lors de la première partie de ce même
match
quand marie avait les blancs alors il ya
un peu plus de pions mais il ya bien un
pion passé à house est bon peu importe
c'est je crois aussi que le pion c'est
qu'elle avait plus ou moins bella même
plombée et en un pion pas ch pour les
noirs est ce qu'on a vu c'est que maria
vérifiait la gagne est bon avec des
possibilités de nuls pour pour
l'adversaire alors là donc la question
celle inverse
c'est marc alyn ware cette fois est ce
qu'elle sera en mesure elle de trouver
le plan 2 nuls bon est ce qu'il ya un
plan de nuls probablement dit toujours
les finales de tours sont toujours nous
le sert c'est très dur à gagner et c'est
parce que ça bouge dans tous les sens
une tour c'est très difficile de
calculer
en fait c'est très difficile de tout
calculer les blancs jouent tour aux
trois tours 3 c'est intéressant
l'idée simplement cette tour j'ai trois
échecs puis on prend tout reprendre puis
on prend et les blancs gagne parce que
les noirs pourront pas arrêter ses deux
pions la voilà et le roi blanc va
tranquillement manger ses pions comme le
pion sera à angers il empêchera une
structure y aura pas de plan passés pour
les noirs et ses deux ont peut pas
prendre les deux pions avec les noirs
ici je vous la fais pas mis la finale de
pions quand on imagine donc on est roi
ici le roi se baladent là quand on
attaque il suffit de pousser leurs pions
si l' on pousse l'autre pillant on a
amené une barrière on imaginer le pion à
quatre on a une petite barrière
le roi ne peut pas aller aux bestiaux et
s'il prend mais sur l'autre il file à
dam on peut pas l'arrêter
donc on est obligé de revenir et si on
vient de l'autre côté on fait pareil on
pousse on pousse et on aura de nouveau
une barrière voilà c'est que ces deux
pions arrive à se protéger l'un l'autre
contre roy c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut analyser mais ça marche très bien
donc là marie veut éviter tout rejet
trois bons
évidemment donc là il faut trouver un
coup et elle fait sans doute le meilleur
tour âges de tous âges deux évite tout
rejet trois échecs ça s'est réglé mais
bon tour h2c à la fois bien et pas bien
parce que la tour en h2 l empêche pas le
pion d'avancé et puis que son g2 ou un
jeu de en termes d'activité excusez moi
mais c'est pas terrible donc là c'est
l'heure pour les blancs c4 très bien ces
quatre à noter que la tour 3 protège ses
trois on a joué ses 4 on peut mettre la
tour derrière le pion et pousser c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle il va falloir il
faut absolument aller assez vite je
pense avec les noirs aller chercher ses
pions en hongrois et si cela semblait
obligatoires
au lieu de quoi les noirs jouent trop
vite leur tour il faut tout racheter
quatre ça me paraît pas bon je pense
qu'il faut pas trop jouer la tour dans
cateau et l'a finalement le pion f 2,8
emprise il faut que les blancs jouent
d'abord soit touriste 3 qui est pas
terrible
soit je sais pas quoi c'est pas évident
d'ailleurs wave 3 mais dans ce cas là on
va pas protéger les pions je pense qu'il
faut y aller victoire
il faut jouer roi m6 et surtour échec
bon on va chercher ses pions là parce
que là on a deux donc la limite bon si
on en perd un et puis je vois pas
comment un père d'un enfant va jouer g5
c'est très difficile a dit prendre ses
deux pions ses deux pions contiennent
celui là donc il faut avait le roi noir
allaient bloquer ses pions passé
bontemps clatot elle avoue bien on peut
pas bloquer oui mais si les blancs
avance trop leurs pions cette fois la
tour va s'activer et on va réussir à
prendre avec le roi noir qui sera bien
placé vers le centre donc je pense que
le plan là c'était 3 et 6 et les rois
d'aller bloquer ses pions passé ce qui
peut toujours se faire en finale deux
tours et au contraire la tour devrait
rester elle sur la 8e par exemple c'est
kobe les pions et
éventuellement faire des manoeuvres pour
arriver à changer ses deux pions contre
1 voilà et après on a une finale
philidor tourbillon contre tours avec le
roi qu'on bloque ici et ça gagne pas
mais à condition que le roi justement
soit s'approche vite entourage quatre ça
c'est trop tôt parce que ça permet roi
des trois et on a activé le roi lors
c'était pas la peine il y avait le pion
f qui l'obligé à rester là bas ça me
paraît pas bon alors tôt f4
effectivement je viens réattaquer
l'heureux et les blancs s'en foutent c5
alors ça
les scorpions alors qu'est ce qui se
passe bien sûr et là il faut calculer
c'est à ce que la tour prends un f2
évidemment mais bon c'est 6 il faut
arrêter ce pion qu'on fait pas simple
alors par exemple si on essaie de jouer
tous réussissent est ce que ça marche
parce que attention sinon elle va
bloquer les pions c'est intéressant
parce qu'on a deux pions ici qui sont
passés liés mais ses pions sur les
options est déjà très avancé c'est le
problème ça va vite
donc là imaginons tous rêvent 6 si les
noirs pousse sans doute s'est il faut
quand même jouer sa tour par exemple ces
six bons et belle à regarder
pouf haye mauvaise nouvelle échec
et si la tour prends mais en dame alors
la dame de gagner il reste en plus un
pion à l'amitié resterait pas le pion
peut-être on peut retenir avec les noirs
de pions touré deux pions contre dame je
pense que c'est peut-être ça fait nul
mais mais pas avec le pion de plus la
manoeuvre donc on peut pas faire ça donc
si on fait une autre possibilité c'est
de jouer directement touré fuite
contrôlée simplement la case de
promotion le roi par exemple vacances et
maintenant on met en route
sans doute oui on est en route ses pions
il faut il faut y aller alors c'est pas
la même qu'en dans la partie d'hier
puisque on a deux pions qui peuvent se
soutenir
ils sont passés liés donc on peut
sacrifier la tour contre le pion qui
viendrait faire dame et les deux pions
c'est pas sûr que la tour on va même
s'il n'y avait pas le saut pions là
c'est sûr que les noirs s'en sortent
voire même gagne peuvent gagner la
partie
parce que depuis on lier on sacrifie la
dame contre la tour la tour pardon
contre le pion qui n'importe quoi et
après on deux pions on va on va gagner
donc voyez un ce plan là bon alors donc
je reviens la partie 3 f 7 tours 2 voilà
maintenant blanc en protège on pouvait
plus et c'était autre chose n'a pas osé
et là un tour à 4 rejoue la tour bon
c'est vrai que le roi est venu en relève
taylor mais là bon tour à 4 les blancs b
il laisse tomber ses 6 ils avancent tous
rishek trois des quatre
toi hein vous voyez donc là les noirs
ont fait de jeu trop de coups de tours
voilà ce coup là tout à leur tour h4
était pas bon encore une fois avancé le
roi d'abord sans doute été mieux pour
ces 2
et là maintenant ne lasse c7 et c'est
fini parce que les noirs peuvent pas
empêcher le pion de faire dame donc là
la solution c'est de faire des échecs
jusqu'à ce que le roi passe sur la
colonne s'est par exemple 3,5 torts
échec au roi des six mais il s'avance de
la protection du pion tour d un droit
c'est cette alors ces structures à l'epa
bonin ça c'est typique une position très
désagréable à tour derrière le pion bon
on dirait c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile dès que je sors le roi je prends
des échecs oui mais on va l'amener
jusqu'à ses 7 et après quand le roi sort
si on fait des échecs on remonte quand
la terre est attaquée ne peut pas venir
embellir le pion c'est empêche donc là
on sent déjà que ça allait carottes
commence à sentir la cuisse ont fini
l'un donc c'est dur c'est une position
qui va pas il faudrait que tout soit le
roi noir qui sont devant mais on a perdu
beaucoup trop de temps avec la tour tôt
moi c'est 8 ça y est roy s'est vite pour
éviter les échecs h5 bon c'est peut-être
un peu tendu effectivement commencé à
pousser les pions
et oui c'est pareil qui hier aussi la
même idée c'est que le roi est quand
même loin là c'est à dire si on pouvait
sacrifier la tour contre le pian avec un
endroit plus proche en f4 par exemple ça
serait pas la même mais il est trop loin
trop loin
donc l'idée de on n'a pas le peut pas
empêcher à la fois les pions d'avancé et
est protégé des pions ici là il faut
choisir
c'est soit on laisse les deux blancs
faire dame soit ce qu'on n'a pas le
temps
ces sept alors là bon taureau 7 mai déjà
s'assemblent se ressemblent puis on peut
pas empêcher la dame de se faire trois
des huit bons à noter que la marie
aurait pu gagner du temps échec
tout reprend
et là mon peut-être les blancs un
meilleur ou 7 mieux de prendre de la
tour mais le roi c'est pareil bon ça s
éloigne un peu loin mais en fait on peut
pas gagner ça alors ce pion là est
bloqué par celui-là bon c'est un premier
point et si celui là avance trop loin la
tour l'attaqué et après dés qu'il avance
on vient le chercher
on va aussi coupé le roi ça même idée
qui hier on va l'empêcher d'avancer trop
loin royal 6 3 des 6 et puis le roi
blanc est pas loin voilà donc on n'a pas
de problème bref cinq bons les rois sont
en opposition mais simplement à leur
tour ces cinq échecs projet 4 pour
essayer de protéger l'avancé du pion
mais la jolie f3 alors là que font et
que font les noirs problème échec petit
coup inattendu
si on vient h 4 on peut et sylvian h 4
on bloque l'avancée de son pion là on
permet au roi aux blancs d'avancé
simplement en 6 et si on pousse l'autre
pion au roi f5 qui est ça y est les
pions noirs seront perdus on va prendre
quand même tout reprend simplement joue
maintenant roi f4 en espérant que
l'opposition des rois empêche laurent
blanc devenir s'approcher du pion et on
va jouer gsm g4g 3 et puis on va essayer
comme ça ce pion peuvent alors une tour
mais bon c'est que ça marche pas si le
roi est trop près vous allez voir échec
bon pourquoi pas en 5 3 des 5 héros en
opposition gsm qui pour ses bons il faut
y aller maintenant et la tourache 8
donc l'idée c'est on va jouer tous
riches est le roi va être obligé de
venir sur le pion sur la commune g et
après le roi blanc on peut s'approcher
on peut pas on a besoin que l'europe
protège le pion mais le roi blanc
à permettre de repousser le roi noir en
le menaçant de maths aussi sur le sur le
couloir sur la borne sur le côté
hongrois f4 simplement voilà il faut
suivre ensuite on va des cas très bien
j'ai quatre essais d'avancé le pion mes
échecs et ça y est le roi est obligé de
venir
alors si le roi venait manger sain qui
s'éloigne de la du pion simplement bien
aux 3 f 2 juin et ce puis on va finir
par le prendre donc là roi j'ai trois
ans viennent devant le pion mais dans ce
cas là il n'avance pas simplement roi 3
et la marie abandonne faut que les noirs
jouent le roi par exemple en thiérache
détient h2 pour pour permettre aux pions
d'avancé bombay simplement on peut faire
tout rejet 8 ça suffit le pion est
attaqué et si on joue g3 par exemple eh
bien simplement wild 3 il sait finir
contrôler le pion sera pris soin en g3
soit en g2 et bien sûr raconté tour
contre roye sagan donc togo nina ici
revient dans le match un match bon qui
s'équilibre avec une deuxième une partie
revanche curieuse un peu varié joue
quand même une bonne ouverture joue
assez bien les cool s'en sort assez bien
mais dépensent un temps fou ce qui
malheureusement ce qui lui
ce qui l'handicape lui permet pas de
voir comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure des
manoeuvres de contre attaque fou 17
pouces et 6 voilà qui était une très
belle manoeuvre qui très certainement
lui aurait assuré un jeu dynamique
qu'elle aime bien en plus
mais bon évidemment si on dépense 1h30
en seize coups on veut un coup et qui
nous reste juste cinq minutes pour jouer
un coup forcément on fait des coûts
faibles c'est ce qui est arrivé donc
voilà donc c'est un problème de marie je
pense dans ce championnat du monde alors
on le voit depuis le début il fait des
ouvertures où elle sort pas vraiment
avec un avantage mais s'en sort après
derrière grâce à son grand talent mais
en terme de préparation il semble
qu'elle soit quand même un peu courte
face à des joueuses par contre très bien
préparée et qui jusqu'à présent sortent
quasiment tout le temps de l'ouverture
avec un avantage face à elle donc ça
c'est pas bon si à chaque fois ils
doivent remonter les parties pour
espérer les gagner c'est quand même
extrêmement délicat bon tie break quand
même il ya une place en quart de finale
à jouer
tout est possible même si forcément se
faire remonter comme ça c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour la suite mais bon
tout est encore possible c'est les
parties rapides faut rappeler quand même
que justement étant donné que les dans
les rapides l'ouverture compte eux -
marie est certainement beaucoup plus
forte en partie rapide qu'en partie
longue encore plus ambitieux peut-être
donc
tout est possible et certainement on
peut espérer que mari gagne c'est
tie-break et donc se qualifier pour les
quarts de finale ça va être passionnant
donc à suivre
au revoir